reg Pauly just sent me the 1987 draft
you were involved in the 1987 draft you
had David Robinson go number one trying
to think now so if we're talking about
today's NBA if we redid the 1987 draft
so let's just look at this David
Robinson number one he'd still go number
one in your opinion right correct okay
then I've got Armand Gilliam you're
better than him
Dennis Hobson you're better than him
Reggie Williams from Georgetown you're
better than him then it's Scottie Pippen
that's close it's today's NBA Kenny
Smith Kevin Johnson let me see you went
11th overall so if I redid that draft
are you going second overall are you
glory in terms of today yeah a of how
they play the reason oh god yes it's
wide open and freedom of movement
absolutely because I think David
Robinsons would still be number one
because he could play in any era because
he could face you up he could play with
his back to the basket he ran like a
deer so he would be a perfect fit in
today's NBA as well Scottie Pippen I
think kids would probably have a better
career in today's game than he did
coming out in 87 just want a simple
factor of how the game is played at the
point guard dominated League but I'm
happy where I landed I believe things
always happen for a reason Theodore and
where did I ever give him the number to
pick 3-legged he was it Philly yeah
where did arm and Gilliam go there's no
hoppin Jersey and Reggie Williams up
going to the Clippers where did Armen
end up going number two I thought he was
Philly
um now Phoenix later oh so thank God 11
to Indiana because on draft day I barely
had
an interview with Donnie Walsh in
Indiana I had no idea I was going to
Indiana
I flew in literally for two hours walked
into the Pacers office shipped Donnie
who lost his hand God rest his soul Mel
Daniels is in the office as well he
almost broke my hand tried to shake my
hand
they asked me two questions and I was on
my way back to the airport
there was no I said to myself there's no
way I'm coming to Indiana
it was barely an interview my toughest
and where they told me I was going was
to play with Sir Charles at 16 in
Philadelphia so I was all set going to
Philadelphia and then when 11 came
around and I was sitting on that bad
couch with Cheryl in Riverside and we
had to here you know we had the earplugs
in and we could hear - you're talking
like oh we're going to Riverside we're
going to Reggie at 11 I looked at sure
she was like I like history so for the
kids who barely had great interviews
don't go by that because Donnie Walsh
played his hand well he barely said
three words to me and I was a pacer the
most interesting team right now for next
season is who New Orleans absolutely
Orleans I think over the Lakers yes
because unless come June 30th July 1st
they had another superstar look you're
gonna get the buzz with LeBron and happy
Davis that's an unbelievable one-two
punch and they're definitely back in
championship discussion don't get me
wrong but I think having these young
superstars like Diane Williamson John
Moran and in Memphis having these guys
in smaller markets I think it injects
life for the first time in a long time
Dan there are so much parity in the NBA
because you know the last what five six
years you and I every week every week we
talked about it is it Golden State or
the field
yeah builder Golden State right
but the injuries the Golden State and
with what the Laker said it's wide open
I mean there are 12 to 15 teams that you
are really excited about if they made
the right moves
if these rookies and free agents pan out
and they're playing well at the right
time after the all-star break next
season they have a legitimate shot look
at Toronto Toronto quite littered went
15 a few years ago he was the highest
ranked player on that team and they
ended up winning the championship so
it's all about selecting well for these
Journal managers and presidents and
scouting departments and teams gelling
parity is at an all-time high now a PA
if you take out Zion which top pick
makes the all-star game first Marant
Barrett hunter garland Pulver well Paul
Barrett is going to have a huge push
from that New York media and he's going
to have the ball in his hands a lot I
believe so I will go with Barrett and I
think he I think he is built he said
this himself
I think he's built for New Yorkers you
got to have broad shoulders and you've
got to have tough skin and just by his
demeanor and watching him for a season
at Duke I think you know again take out
Zion because I'm going to have I think a
great year as well take out Zion I think
RJ Pierre with that New York Knicks in
that media the number of media markt a
push
I think Derrick has a Barrett has a
chance to be great but I'm kind of
focusing a little bit on the lower end
of the NBA draft lottery you know what
Miami did getting Tyler here Oh
remember devin booker when he was picked
a few years ago and people are like well
he could shoot he's good but did he
barely play to Kentucky right and the
same thing with Tyler here oh he was
good he can really shoot but he wasn't
the main focus at Kentucky so I think
the heat getting hero
I think the Celtics getting Romeo
Langford this guy in a sub injury all
season long and he's not a shooter he's
more of a scorer and with everything and
the turmoil and you know what is Kyrie
going to do at Al Horford I think this
is a good chance for Romeo Langford Brad
Stevens knows his Indiana if he knows it
at the end of guys I think for a hero
they have a chance to be pretty good
players in the NBA what happened to the
Celtics reg to me all season long it
look like it was a chemistry problem
what they did without Kyrie two seasons
ago in the playoffs was phenomenal
and they played as a team with you know
around Kadem and Brown and the ball
movement for whatever reason and it's
not on Kyrie it really is it it just
didn't fit and you know what Al Horford
I thought he was the most important
piece on this team and for him to you
know opt out and now it looks like he's
going somewhere else it's not a redo I
think they're going to retool it a
little bit and try to build around those
two young players at Tatum and brown but
it didn't fit it just did not fit
Saiyans already said he's not gonna be
in the slam dunk contest did ya
he says he doesn't like them oh yeah you
gotta be kidding
so here's the problem they missed out
they should have got a broad James when
he was a rookie to do the slam dunk
competition
Donegan signed it you've got to get Zion
to do the sound down competition I mean
that's what when you think of Zion you
think of YouTube in those dunk I get it
that you want to develop your game
that's great and you can still do that
you can still do that but one way to put
the pelicans again back on the map and
not only yourself you've got to be able
to do the slam dunk competition reg
maybe Zion just doesn't want to be known
as I'm I'm a dunker okay but you are a
dumb
okay I get it but you know I get it I
understand that but what is putting
people in the seats those 360s in those
colorful dunks so why why people want
that we do it every year
but as a rookie you got to do it yeah
well you know there's what's the upside
he's supposed to win and if he doesn't
win yeah but it's good oh I'm all for
that
okay every time we played this game I
always take the field Tiger would build
Golden State or the field I always take
the field yeah
this one time I would go with Zions
versus the field I would take Zion in a
slam dunk competition at next all-star
game I'm going with Zion you can have
the field what if I take JAMA rant I'm
going with okay because see I'll get
degree of difficulty for having a guy
who's six - where is Zion supposed to be
great it's like when spud Webb won it we
were fascinated that a guy that small
could win you know the novelty of it so
I I would take I would take Jama rant
but die on now he doesn't he have power
powerful dunks but he has a lot of grace
as well just a man 16 through the legs
and he has a lot of artistic flair to
his dunk dunk as well so I'm taking fire
what if we had a young fella what if we
had an old-time dunk contest you can
have the doctor cave either right dr. J
Jordan nominee Vince Vince
anybody else you want to throw in there
I would look Robin no one ever gives
meat Robinson a lot of love it what is
he a three or four times dunk champion
so I would throw a Nate Robinson in
there and as well as Zion so what is
that six and and who else you're going
to throw in there Terrence Stansbury
and oh no no I'm ready Mary here's
another one the Lance Larry Larry hands
lettering in Larry Nance Jr writer mmm
good good okay but who wins that Wow I
will always say this Vince Carter
I would go with Vince Carter winning
that over that all-star collection of
names we just mentioned I would either
go with Vince or dr. J and not Mike Mike
was great
Michael is probably the best in-game
dunker who else was a great ingame
dunker I would probably go with let me
see who you always say watch your head
with I mean Dominique trolley dunk on
every gym Journal document ooh okay yeah
we forgot about that Darryl Dawkins yeah
chocolate fender yeah
[Music]
Shaq oh yeah
well that should be excluded from this
because Shaq brought down the whole
backboard right I mean come on
so actually be included is that because
of his size it's like it's not fair with
Shaq did the Lakers overpay with Anthony
Davis but will we look back how will we
look back on this five years from now
well you will still have Anthony Davis
in the Lakers uniform so no I think he
had to make this that move that's why I
think New Orleans is going to be such an
entry team maybe only for this year you
could die on out there with Ingram ball
heart
Alvin Gentry coaching and let's say the
Lakers do not make another big-time move
they don't get another like Mack salary
type player and then now you have to
feel LeBron and Anthony Davis with just
shooters telling what they did this past
year who has a better record between New
Orleans and the Lakers that was my next
question
I think those young those young cats in
New Orleans are gonna have a lot of
proving to do I like what New Orleans is
doing just for this one here because you
know eventually the Lakers will get with
those two players they will get another
player but if they the Lakers they're in
the championship talk but they've got to
stay healthy
Anthony Davis yes he can't stay healthy
and we saw this year LeBron James at
what 34 35 he broke down a little bit
yeah so can those two guys stay healthy
I'll leave you with this Howard Beck of
bleacher report was on with us yesterday
and he said you know let's we're not
even getting into this discussion
there's no discussion that the guys that
New Orleans got in Lonzo ball and
Brandon are better than Kyle Koosman he
said it's not even an argument well
they've got some proving to do two ball
has to prove that he can stay on the
court okay but who would you rather have
out of those three you're gonna start
your team with one of those three
I like who's why I told you that was the
one guy I'm glad they were able to keep
yeah so I like Sousa yeah Ingram well
England was just coming into his own
towards the end of last season and he
got hurt Hart is a good you know three
and D type player it's going to be
fascinating just for next season who has
a better record between the pelicans and
the Lakers if if the Lakers don't get a
kalaiy or a kimba if they don't get a
player like that and it's just those two
superstars along with Kyle coos but
it'll be interesting to see
who has a better record because it's
going to be closer than people think
thank you reg as always we appreciate
your time you guys are the best thank
you son it's a Reggie Aloysius Miller
jr. the third if you missed any of the
interviews from the Mercedes AMG mancave
go to the DP show app you can watch and
listen from inside the Mercedes AMG
mancave Mercedes AMG driving performance
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]